i feel like i am living like a fairy
tale
making like new memories and new moments
and i don't necessarily want scott at
all of them kourtney kardashian isn't
letting scott disick ruin her newlywed
bliss with travis barker i'm not putting
my energy there a source tells e.t
courtney couldn't be more in love and
happier
and we're told the blushing bride is
loving her new last name which is
proudly on full display on her instagram
page quote she loves signing her name as
mrs barker and everyone is so happy for
her we love that you're this happy and
we love travis yeah but for scott it
just wasn't meant to be you know but he
woe was me
no i know but i'm just telling you from
somebody else's perspective
for courtney she's emotionally done with
her past and focusing on her future and
family our source says the mom of three
knows scott will always be the father of
her kids but she isn't gonna let scott's
feelings ruin her moment and she feels
she's a better mom and person with
travis we're just you know living our
best lives
yeah
the new dynamic with the kardashian
barker crew is playing out on the
family's hulu series including how scott
really feels about courtney stepping
into this new chapter without him he
said this is not the easiest for me and
i just
at the end of the day i want you to be
happy and you know congrats on the
engagement that's nice
i don't really think that me getting
engaged is like about scott like
undeniably my life is going in a
different direction
meanwhile another e.t source is opening
up about scott's mindset explaining he
has mixed feelings because he loves
courtney and has a lot of regrets about
how he treated her when they were
together but their main priority remains
the same their kids and how they're
handling the transition our source says
their three little ones twelve-year-old
mason nine-year-old penelope and
seven-year-old reign are happy for their
mom but naturally always hoped that
there was a chance their parents would
get back together
we got engaged look at mom got a ring
is that upsetting
why are you sad baby
not only is p taking it pretty hard but
her dad is too if you and travis are
cool then we're fine
for me to hear that you are having a
little soiree
and you don't think to invite me makes
me feel like complete
to be honest i love you but like
how do you think i would feel
according to our store scott misses how
close he once was to the kardashian crew
even though he still remains close to
court's sister chloe
have you been i mean don't get me wrong
i'll always love your sister thank god
it does give me a lot of relief that
like she's happy somebody else is taking
care of her
i always felt like that was my
fault for breaking up our family
[Music]
you